tell me a little bit about the Hajj I
get us with my water for of course
because this is such a tall tale Hajj is
it's a pilgrimage to Mecca Saudi Arabia
and it's a requirement to do once in
your lifetime my mother invited me and I
was at a kind of low point in my life I
was getting cast in Hollywood and
playing the terrorists so I was
perpetuating and feeding the stereotype
and then the day before I was leaving
for Hajj I got a bunch of calls for
auditions and I called my mom I was like
oh I can't leave Hollywood's knocking on
my door and she said you know why you're
going to Hajj right and I said yeah you
invited me and she's like now God
invited you you can only come by
invitation from God so now I'm like what
do I say to God I kept there you know
sorry I haven't been in touch my phone
was on vibrate
it's kind of spooky you know when we
arrived at the main mosque I remember it
looking like the religious las vegas we
were driving through the mountains at
night they kind of opened up and there
was this glimmering spectacle of lights
and pulsating energy we pulled up on
this balcony overlooking the Kaaba which
is the black box building right in the
heart of Mecca the Prophet Mohammed
throughout all the statues and claimed
that there's one God and there's
millions of pilgrims some coming in on
first-class flights others are walking
their camels through the desert with
packed bloody feet the height of the
high and the low of the low then
everything in between
and everyone's dressed in white and I
remember looking over at my mother and
she was on her knees crying
and so of course you know that made me
cry it's a hard buckle and I started
crying and it was just this magnificent
feeling and force of something so much
bigger than you
epic out of a movie it's futuristic they
say in Islam that Hajj is a small
version of what the day of judgment is
going to look like and feel like so it's
like a dress rehearsal you were supposed
to go to Hajj when you have sinned all
that you were supposed to sin and in
order to clean your sins and kind of
push the restart button I went at a time
when you know I was 27 years old I'm 42
now so you know I gotta go back
you